Donald J Trump to be allowed back on
Facebook and Instagram so here's a
question for you
a couple months ago he first is back on
Twitter now Facebook and Instagram let
him back on which one they say Facebook
and Instagram really what they're saying
is Facebook because Facebook owns
Instagram so the last one that hasn't
said it yet is who is YouTube and I
don't even know if he's on LinkedIn or
not but YouTube is the only one that's
left to let him back on the question I
got for you is why are
the the top three most traffic websites
social media companies three out of the
five Twitter Facebook Instagram why are
they bringing them back on at a time
like this is it one they're sick and
tired of Biden and they just want this
guy to come in is it two they're afraid
that McCarthy is about to go out there
and investigate the hell out of them so
before doing that they're already
letting them lose two weeks after
McCarthy wins speaker of the house oh
[__] you know what just to be nice and
play nice let's let Trump back on
Facebook and Instagram is that two or
three it's just about time for us to let
him back on it's it's business plan just
like you said with the vaccine they're
putting it in a drink right now they
know you know it's coming he's gonna now
you know he already announced he's gonna
be running for president you know much
traffic is going to be on their sites
he's gonna be he's gonna be on Instagram
he's gonna be on Facebook because
they're connected right Tom what are you
gonna be all over it I think what's
going on below the surface is Operation
bid bid Biden investigations DeSantis
Facebook is worried about the
investigations with McCarthy I think
you're absolutely right they want
nothing to do with a chair and on
Capitol Hill asking questions they also
I believe are fearing DeSantis the more
these polls come out although there are
some polls this week that show Trump was
doing much better
and I think it was not the
establishment's desire for
Biden to come out and say I've talked to
my wife Jill and I were absolutely
running remember that was kind of
impromptu this guy impromptu that was
not set up that was not a big
announcement I think there are people in
the Democrat machine who are like the
DNC were like dug on it he's not
supposed to do that and I think that
they the machine wants him not to run
Tech was worried about investigations
and also they're worried about the
Santas well what better way to help
neutralize DeSantis than to fomat
Conflict at the RNC level the easiest
way to do that let the orange man back
onto
Twitter let him back onto Facebook and
let let the dust kept kick up on the
dispute I think um sometimes I by the
way I think all of you guys have some
credibility with your stories right and
and it's easy to go what you did bis I
think it's a b.i
bid I think sometimes there's these
Rabbit Hole stories we can go down a lot
of them have some truthiness to them
sometimes it's just sometimes it's in
plain sight two years ago and two weeks
to the day there was January 6th
Insurrection how this whole thing
started of of banning Donald Trump and
they put a two-year ban on Donald Trump
voila it's two years later and sometimes
it's just as easy as plain sight saying
well it's been two years we've been for
two years and it's time to put them back
on now I do think there's a lot of
credibility behind there like there's
nuanced discussions what happens if we
bring them on to Santa's buy and
investigate I think all that is credible
but I think the the major factor is it's
like it's reached the two-year Mark and
it's time to reconsider having them on
has he tweeted has he tweet did he has
he still hasn't tweeted no so that's
just people I love love
[Music]
um
how uh simple you think this is on on on
what they're doing with this let them
back on uh I think there's a lot of a
lot of strategy behind what's going on I
think Twitter was just letting back on I
don't think there was anything with
Twitter I think you know uh musk is like
sitting there saying look I'd love to
have the mega crowd back on Twitter
that's traffic that'll increase the
valuation the company I'm all in I think
to I think to musk is truly
let's get the guy back into business
that's right okay and he's waiting for
this right come on sweet something by
the way the moment the moment Trump
tweets it'll be the most liked tweet in
the history of Twitter the moment he
tweets it's gonna happen and they're
saying he's about to by the way oh
really his Camp is saying he's about to
okay
um
Facebook and Instagram is is slightly
different on why you let them back on uh
could it be ad money because ad money's
taking a massive hit with Facebook
they're having a hard time with that and
they know if Trump runs that campaign
they're going to spend a lot of AD money
on Facebook and the one that was a
machine last time was Facebook more than
YouTube more than Twitter more than
everybody it was Facebook Facebook was
the machine that helps with elections so
they want that money and that's a lot of
money that goes to Facebook right
um you know that could be one side the
other part is you know they they may
want him to come in to make it dirtier
against the Santas because he is going
to go against the scientists or it could
be a civil war where it could be them
going against each other and they like
that they want that remember when you
think about your opponent never
underestimate your opponent and how
strategic how manipulative they could be
the Demps lead the game in manipulation
and propaganda in uh creating
is going around destroying rioting fires
buildings CNN headquarters but then
people are protesting at uh you know
what do you call it uh January 6th this
is an Insurrection this is this and then
the guy on TV says I love the fact that
they're using violent with antifa just
because you're destroying property that
doesn't mean it's violent violence is
when it's towards other human beings do
you understand like they're processing
on how they're and how many people have
died with these antifa protests are
walking around with guns and riots and
how many people died with the January 6
protesting unless if you put data to
data together but what was turned into a
massive event historic the single worst
event ever worse than 9 11 was what are
you talking about right but this right
here leave them alone these people are
upset ask why they're doing this so they
they get credit for games
they get credit for that uh the one
company that we're not talking about
right now that we should notice how
Facebook allows Trump back on Instagram
and Facebook and Twitter but then Google
gets crushed this week okay I don't know
if you saw the story with Google they
get crushed cover a Wall Street Journal
main story the government is soon Google
for the second time in two and a half
years and they're going after them to
wanting them to split up okay you know
their ad Revenue couple years ago they
were number one at 34 billion or
whatever and then they're at 21 billion
right now they're they're behind I
believe Tick Tock and Amazon or Tick
Tock and Amazon is catching up to them
but they're saying hey it's manipulation
it's gamesmanship not the right way of
doing this you're listening to what
people are doing so they want to divide
those guys up so maybe Google comes out
in the next week or two and says hey
we're letting Trump back on YouTube
because they also want Kevin McCarthy in
their Camp to take it easy on them so
all of this stuff is very uh seems very
like ah it's just day-to-day business as
usual I don't think it is on Google I'll
add one quick quick point the attorney
generals for the state of New York and
the state of California have joined the
feds in their suit
well here connect the dots on that isn't
that crazy New York and California New
York and California attorney generals
have joined the federal suit
if you want that interesting behind the
scenes somebody's upset there you go New
York Times story right here U.S accuses
Google of abusing Monopoly and Pad
technology the doj and eight states have
filed an Anti-Trust lawsuit against
Google accusing it of illegally abusing
a monopoly over the technology that
powers online advertising as a first
such lawsuit against the tech giant
under President Biden and an escalation
of legal pressure on one of the world's
biggest internet companies these are the
states by the ways you're not I'm
looking at the lawsuit right now it's 15
153 Pages it's it's the US government
U.S Department of Justice Commonwealth
of Virginia state of California state of
Colorado state of Connecticut state of
Jersey state of New York State of Rhode
Island state of Tennessee jeez
outside of Tennessee those are all blue
States that's exactly I was about to say
why is Tennessee in there so Tennessee's
also getting involved the lawsuit says
Googles has quote unquote corrupted
legitimate competition there's our
favorite word competition in the ad tech
industry by engaging in systematic
campaign to seize control of the wide
swath of high-tech tools used by
Publishers advertisers and Brokers to
facilitate digital advertising what was
the number that that constitutes a
monopoly was it 60 percent
64 or 16. real quick what makes a
monopoly yeah is this 64. we're about to
find that that's not that crazy huh 64
of the market share and I think last
year didn't Google right
50.50 right
what's the number
at what percentage does it become a
monopoly
uh I don't know why by the way while
you're saying this uh the lawsuit doj
has asked the U.S District Court of
eastern district of Virginia to here it
is force Google to sell much of its
Suite of AD technology products and to
stop the company from engaging in
allegedly anti-competitive practices
well when they bought doubleclick and
they rolled it into AdSense it basically
there was certainly any Ad Agency in
America there was really only one place
to go
yeah that they had a monopoly for a
minute they don't anymore like they did
before though but they're still being
targeted so that's correct it
again a lot of these decisions are being
made right after midterms knowing that
they lost house and by the way I love
the fact that the other day Robert
Wright comes out and says so you know
the the house what are you now gonna do
about what's going on with the you know
uh guns and with unemployment and with
minimum wage I'm like dude for two years
two and a half years you had house
you had sent it and you had the White
House you didn't do [__] so what the
hell are you talking about bro what are
you talking about so again that's the
gamesmanship that is so good on what's
done on the other side you have to give
the level of manipulation that they do
you got to give them credit You Gotta
Give Them credit I always do I always
you can't underestimate the power of
what those guys do on that side okay so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]